[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello.
I'm Timothy Jordan for
"The Developer Show."
This is your update on
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
There's a new Kotlin boot
camp course on Udacity.
It's free, self-paced,
and teaches
you everything you need to
know to program in Kotlin.
A link to the course
is on the post,
which is linked in
the description below.
The Firebase Cloud
Messaging v1 REST API
has integrated fully with
the Web Notifications API.
So you can now set
icons, images, actions,
and more for your web
notifications from your server.
Sample code and links to
screenshots are on the post.
We've developed a set of
five deep dive courses
to help you build
production-ready
machine-learning
models that scale.
They're based on the same
content that has trained
thousands of Google engineers.
And they're available as a
machine-learning specialization
on Coursera.
Course highlights and a link
to get started are on the post.
Cloud ML Engine enables
you to train and deploy
machine-learning models on data
sets of many types and sizes
using the flexibility
and production
readiness of TensorFlow.
And now Cloud ML Engine
offers the option
to accelerate training with
Cloud TPUs as a beta feature.
Getting started is easy,
since Cloud TPU quota is now
available to all GCP customers.
The guide to get started
is linked from the post.
Google Kubernetes Engine 1.10
is now generally available.
Along with this, we are
introducing new features
to support enterprise use
cases, including shared
virtual private cloud for
better control of your network
resources, regional persistent
disks and regional clusters
for higher availability
and stronger SLAs,
and node auto-repair GA
and custom horizontal pod
autoscaler for
greater automation.
Chrome 64 Beta has a
stronger pop-up blocker,
supports resize observer to give
web applications finer control
to observe changes to sizes
of elements on a page,
supports imports.meta
to make it easier
to access host-specific metadata
about the current module,
and more.
All the details are on the
post linked in the description
below.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan for
"The Developer Show."
Thanks for watching.
And we'll see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Uh, [INAUDIBLE], yeah.
How'd that taste?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I
did not lick it.
SPEAKER: Many people
have touched that.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Mm.
Good.
Germs.
Germs are important.